happy Halloween I am Walter benezia
canned welcome to 2017 s final October
top 5 today we continue to cover are you
afraid of the dark with its best
gruesome ghouls as I said in my best
episode list there's a lot I wanted to
cover with this show just five episodes
weren't enough I didn't get to focus on
what made this show scary the monsters a
good portion of the episodes I put in my
best list didn't feature the best
villains from the show some of them did
but I felt like the truly scary monsters
deserve their own list thus I have
excluded those villains from today's
countdown to break down characters that
I haven't covered yet no repeats one
more time submitted for the approval of
the channel awesome society
I call this countdown the top 5 best are
you afraid of the dark monsters number 5
Zeebo the clown from the tail of
laughing in the dark
Zeebo is pretty well known among fans of
the show and was featured in one of its
earliest episodes Zeebo was a clown in
the 1920s who stole his circuses payroll
and when chased by police ran into a
nearby funhouse while hiding he dropped
his cigar and was trapped inside as the
funhouse burned down around him he
perished in the flames but years later
the funhouse was rebuilt and a Zeebo
dummy was installed at the ending in
this tale a boy named Josh brazenly
steals the Zeebo dummies nose on a dare
however that didn't sit well with Zeebo
himself as Josh begins to realize just
what he has done once again scary clowns
are in right now but Zeebo is much more
subtle than a character like penny wise
it's about what you don't see
[Music]
[Applause]
z-bo is all intimidation and in the
creepiest way possible this is my
favorite bit from the episode
there's definitely a mystery surrounding
a few elements of Z Bo's haunting and
the spook house as they call it like the
circus carnie in front of Z Bo's
funhouse he obviously knows what's going
on
is he Zeebo without the makeup what's
his connection the episode speculates
but never tells us it's the most fun in
fact and you laugh in the fun fact
that's Aaron tagger AKA dr. Vinc he also
voiced Zeebo this is the only time he
ever played another character on the
show and they're both memorable ones
Zeebo has mentioned kind of a lot
throughout the series though we never
got a true sequel in any case Zeebo the
clown is a signature villain on this
show this next one's a real knee-slapper
number 4 the ghastly grin er from the
tail of the ghastly grin a lot of people
were pointing out that this episode was
missing from my best list the ghastly
grin er is an evil killer clown created
by comic book artist Sylvester Uncas
Uncas soon realized he had concocted
something terrible and tried to destroy
his work before it destroyed him
unfortunately the Grinner got him before
he could accomplish his task years later
Uncas his daughter is in possession of
the only printed Grinner comic left and
recruits a young artist named Ethan to
finish
Uncas his last story and finally kill
the evil jester the ghastly Grenier is
known to feed off people's emotions and
leave them blue drooling idiots the
ghastly grin er is up there with Zeebo
as one of the most well known villains
in the series we don't see the Grinner
in person until about 16 minutes into
the episode but the build-up is well
done seeing people fall into the grins
lunacy is almost as unsettling as he is
himself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
when he does show up they do a great job
at making him creepy as hell
[Music]
when he uses his powers to turn someone
mad it's pretty damn terrifying
[Music]
okay no more clowns I hope number three
the dark music monster from the tail of
the dark music I don't see enough
discussion on this one the episode and
villain are great the dark music monster
lives in the root cellar of a house
owned by a man named Niles it's only
active when music plays and consumes
humans by luring them into the cellar
depending on the music that's playing
the monster presents itself in different
forms
Niles great nephew Andy and his family
move into the house when Andy's mother
inherited Andy soon discovers something
area's going on as whenever music is on
near the door it begins to rattle and
eventually opens revealing horrifying
visions I love the concept of this
monster it's a great idea and catalyst
for a story
[Music]
[Applause]
hello the different forms this monster
takes are pretty disturbing the carnival
guy is one of them oh don't stop now son
you're almost
[Music]
but by far the scariest was this giant
doll
[Music]
[Applause]
holy Bulls what the hell just when you
think I can't get any darker for a kid
show the ending tops it
I'll give you have to do
[Applause]
the kids gonna feed people to that thing
goodness gracious this episode all of
this is great of course but the cherry
on top is that Roger from Doug guest
stars in this story
[Music]
you mess with me kid and I'll deck you
coming out Roger you mean post number to
the pool zombie from the tail of the
dead man's float the design of this
thing alone warrants a spot on this list
in the 1950s a graveyard was moved to
make room for the expansion of a high
school all the bodies were taken out of
the ground and placed in the new
location except one the new school
expansion was for a pool and soon open
one night a boy named Joe was swimming
alone when he was inexplicably pulled
underwater the attending lifeguard
Charlie tried to save him
but an unseen force kept Joe underwater
where he eventually drowned three more
people died in a similar fashion and the
pool was closed and boarded up for 40
years the pool zombie is invisible until
a boy named Zeke pours methyl orange
into the pool turning the zombie all red
and revealing his rotting skeletal
appearance the only thing that warns of
this creatures arrival is the strong
smell of decay and acid another great
concept and catalyst for a story just
look at this monster rise out of the
pool
damn so well done I really like the
backstory on this guy it's very smart
and well thought-out the opening scene
setting him up decades earlier was a
strong way to start off the episode
[Music]
[Applause]
yes that is a young Jay Baruchel playing
Joe he would appear on this series a few
more times
once they revived it for the final two
seasons now take a look at more of the
pool zombie in action
[Music]
that is just so cool what a great design
in villain how they beat him with
science isn't a bad ending either
has anyone ever tried to cosplay as the
pool zombie if so I would love to see it
these monsters made us afraid of more
than just the darkest kids and there are
plenty that could have made the list so
here are the ones that just missed the
cut as honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best are you afraid
of the dark monster is the vampire from
the tail of the nightshift it was close
between this guy and the pool zombie but
the vampire might be the most
threatening villain on the show period
this unnamed vampire only needs to feed
every 50 years or so and shift itself to
a hospital to do just that
it can shape-shift into many forms and
uses those guises to infiltrate the
hospital and its staff slowly it turns
almost all of them into zombified
versions of vampires it's up to
volunteer worker Amanda patient Colin
and a resisting new vampire named Felix
to stop him the vampires design is
amazing it has a lot of zombie in it
which makes him that much more chilling
this first appearance in the episode is
maybe the scariest moment of the whole
show
[Music]
you know I don't think I really don't
have to say much just look at this thing
we haven't been properly introduced yet
the craziest stuff in this episode
happens when Amanda lures the vampire to
the roof so Colin can have a shot at
destroying his coffin what happens up
there makes him the best monster in the
series
[Music]
I have to show how they kill him because
that's equally as nuts and epic demise
for a ghoulish villain
[Music]
[Applause]
after watching are you afraid of the
dark and goose bumps back to back I feel
like I have a pretty strong perspective
on the strengths and weaknesses of both
shows but which one is better go ahead
and check out a new video on my personal
channel where I present my thoughts on
this question I want to hear what you
guys think what is your favorite are you
afraid of the dark monster what do you
want me to cover next on the show leave
a comment and let me know to stay in
touch like my facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome Walter B and follow along
on Twitter to take part in more polls
about what may be covered in the future
come back next week for a marvelous new
episode of top 5 happy Halloween
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]